welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down The Last of Us episode 6
trailer the new promo has just hit HBO
and YouTube and throughout this video
we're going to be going through the
Easter eggs hidden details and links to
the game they actually changed up one of
the locations so that it resembles how
it appears in part two because of that
we will be discussing elements of that
game as well if you don't want things
ruined like the street is the street
from part two then I highly recommend
that you turn off now and hopefully I'll
see you Sunday but out of the way thank
you for clicking the video now let's get
into the trailer
I tried with Sam
I wanted to save him
well I reckon it's a lot more
complicated than that
I'm looking for my brother
[Music]
tell me those things that you judge me
for how did those things to Keep Us
Alive we did those things they weren't
things we murdered people be careful who
you put your faith in the only people
who can betray us are the ones we trust
foreign
[Music]
so we start off with the HBO sign over
the night sky yeah we then fade into the
northern lights and catch alien gels
sitting around the campfire this moment
wasn't originally in the game however
there was concept or credit for it that
showed Joel and Ellie together through
the magic of Television they've now
brought this moment back into the story
to flesh out more of their time together
on the road she talks about how she
wanted to save Sam but that didn't work
and that it led to both his and Henry's
death she believed she was the vaccine
but Joel says it's a lot more
complicated than that and this is
clearly the first time that Ellie
started out she's the Cure so far she's
been very confident about it but no
doubt is starting to creep into her mind
with encoder Jackson and get a
split-second shot that's been shown in
previous trailers there were two big
signs here that actually have callbacks
to the game and in the top left we can
see one for the Lights Festival 2003
2003 was when the outbreak happened and
this is another reminder of how
everything in the world stopped in that
year later on in he's at we see lights
lining the street and this is clearly
tying back at that sign for the festival
the lights would obviously have been
placed throughout the town and the setup
and now the Jackson Knights are getting
things rolling so they can light up the
city originally in the game they hadn't
really set up the town yet and you spent
the section with Tommy fixing a Hydro
Dam located outside of it Jackson was
created for part two and the showrunners
are now retroactively making most of the
episode take place there it's also
important to bear in mind that in the
game at this point it was Autumn whereas
here is clearly winter this has clearly
been done that it resembles part two a
lot more and it's the creative team kind
of tying the two things together now to
the right of the light sign we can see
one for the Tipsy bison this was the bar
that appeared in the second game and and
it's where a big moment went down
involving Joel Ellie and a new character
for part two now amongst the streets
Joel sees Tommy their reunion is
different in the game as he met him at
the gates of the dam when the group had
their guns drawn on him
foreign
[Music]
tell the girl to drop hers now
Ellie
it was the lady says
okay
please tell me you're lost
we didn't know the place was occupied
we're just trying to make our way
through through to where they're all
right but you know these people
know him
this is my goddamn brother
Tommy
holy [__]
how you doing baby brother God damn yeah
let me look at you
you're [__] old
easy won't happen to you too
this is Maria
be nice to her she sort of runs things
around here still out they end up
hugging like what we see in that what
about the pair quickly start arguing
with each other with Tommy and gel
talking about the horrible things that
they had to do to survive this is
ripping on a moment in the game in which
the pair discussed their past tell me
those things that you judge me for how
did those things to Keep Us Alive we did
those things they weren't things we
murdered people
is how you're going to repay me huh
repay you for all those goddamn years I
took care of us took care that's what
you call it
I got nothing but nightmares from those
years you survived because of me it
wasn't worth it now next we see Maria
telling Ellie to be careful with who she
puts her faith in this is clearly
talking about Joel and both she and
Tommy know a lot about his past that
she's not privy to in the game Tommy
Maria are married and this may be
something that gets brought up in the
episode as Joel didn't know about the
pair when he first arrived
ma'am thanks for not blowing my head off
would have been embarrassing considering
you're my brother-in-law
[Music]
we all got to get wrangled up at some
point
Ellie right
yeah
what brings you through here
uh
that's kind of a long story
why don't we bring him inside yeah
you hungry
starving
[Music]
foreign
is also there with wet hair and a towel
around her so I'm guessing she just got
showered in one of the houses now next
we see a scene that wasn't in the game
with riders approaching Ellie and Jill
out in the snow it's really difficult to
tell what's going on here as it's a
completely new moment and therefore we
don't really know what's what the people
of Jackson did ride around on Horseback
a lot in part two and with Tommy being
completely different it could be them
discovering the pair if we go back to
the start of the trailer we see Joel and
Ellie with a group of riders that look
like they're wearing similar clothes so
I'm guessing that this is when they come
across the people of Jackson early on in
the episode now in a very interesting
moment it seems like we're getting at
least two sections combined in this one
episode in Jackson Ellie actually ended
up running off and this was because she
learned that Joel was gonna dump her off
on her tummy she rode up in the
wilderness and you had to track her down
with Tommy which is when you encountered
some writers eventually you found her at
a house and then agreed to keep going
with her which is when you set out to
the university this is where the fire
flies were apparently located but upon
arriving there you found it abandoned
except for some monkeys Raiders then
attacked and it seems like that's what's
going on in this scene we catch one
swinging bad at Joel and in the
background we can catch the Firefly
emblem spray painted on a dumpster now
next we cut to A man carrying some
rabbits it's possible that we actually
get three sections in this episode as we
are yet to meet David his part was
introduced with Ellie killing a rabbit
while she was out hunting and you bumped
into him whilst you are both looking for
food we later learned that the Raiders
that attacked you at the University were
part of his group and they could
potentially end the entry with a tease
towards him I think that would be the
perfect way to close that episode 6 and
then you know what's coming for seven
David is one of the creepiest parts of
the first game and he's such a big thing
that I'd love to see teased in this
moment and lastly we catch Joel and Ali
riding away from the hospital while she
shoots backwards this is similar to how
you leave the university and if you look
carefully at Joel he looks like he's
slumped over in the game he got impaled
on some rebar and he was badly wounded
at this point I think this is showing
that the same thing is gonna happen and
it's gonna leave Ali at her most
vulnerable point I think it would be
crazy if we enter with Joel slimming
over like how he does in the game and
then we got a tease of David coming in
showing just how much danger Ellie's
gonna be in episode 7 is likely gonna be
a big one and if all this stuff lines up
then I'm very excited for what's coming
anyway that's a trailer and obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
teaser and what you thought about
episode 5. more than halfway through the
show now and I've been completely
overwhelmed with how many of you are
rocking with me really means a lot and
if you want to support the channel we're
selling a Last of Us Inspired Real fungi
t-shirt which will be linked as the top
comment that's all about our site Zero
edition where we've got tons of merch
that you can pick up and help support
the channel we're also running a
competition right now and giving away
wakanda forever three subscribers on the
15th of February and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video go make sure you subscribe
with notifications on drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
you bake the comments out random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now similar
to you and message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then our Episode by
breakdowns linked on the screen right
now definitely go check it out it's our
best video on the show not even over
hyping it yet go watch it right after
this by the way thanks for singing
through the video I've been Paul peace